spe
m
last
as we as we wait for people to still
come
in reminder again even though you
probably don't need it at this point
that the quiz is on Monday first 30
minutes of class okay so please don't be
late if you've registered at the Moses
Center you need to let them know you're
taking the exam it's not just enough to
register so if you're in the Moses
Center make sure you let them know that
you're taking the exam there because
it's easier if you take it there rather
than here right if you have no idea what
I'm talking about just let it go
by so today we're actually I mean I'll
give you up front today is going to be a
pretty intense day in terms of pieces
coming together so I want to warn you
ahead that that's going to happen but
we're going to build on what we started
last session where we talked about betas
being weighted averages
right and I suggested that you look at
your own
portfolios they saying what there's not
nothing in my portfolio there's obv I
mean that's fine too but if you look at
your own portfolio and you look at what
you have you can get a beta so let's say
you have a third of your money in the
Vanguard 500 Index Fund what's the beta
it's going to be one let's say you have
a third of your money in table so beta
is going to be zero but for all of you
there is an item on your balance sheet
that is not going to show up right now
but it's all about the remember
Corporate Finance is all about the
future right so if you are doing a
forward-looking balance sheet for most
of you what's that missing item on your
balance
sheet why you the MBA program not for
the
intellectual curiosity I would hope I
mean this is not why you come back for
mbas it's because you want to increase
your career earning power right your
biggest
asset that's not in the balance sheet is
your human capital do you think
different jobs have different betas so
associate with
them I was going to say a government job
pretty has a low beta but right now that
might not be
true but basically you pick a job it
comes with a beta mean talk about risk
return tradeoffs right I mean when when
I see people picking jobs purely based
on pay I sometimes wonder whether the
class kind of slip by because there's a
risk return tradeoff you can go work as
a Trader at a hedge fund and make
$350,000 but it comes to the higher beta
because you're very sensitive to what
the market might be doing so think about
it it's something to think about we all
have personal balance sheets we all have
risks associated with them we got to
manage that risk over our lifetime and
as we have dependence and children and
it those things have to be playing into
the play a role and what you invest in
and what jobs you might decide to have
given the riskiness of the job today
though I want to bring that weighted
average concept to looking at companies
remember this entire process I know we
keep forgetting and I keep reminding you
is to come up with a hurdle rate for a
company we came up with a hurdle rate
for Disney we took the risk-free rate
the equity risk premium and then we used
a regression Beta And I said look I'm
using it but I'm not quite comfortable
this is not a number that I want to
build an entire analysis
on and I want to give you an alternative
to regression beta so by the end of
today that regression beta you printed
for your company those of you did I want
you to set it aside but from because
this point on the beta you will use for
your company will be based on what we
talk about
today B is are weighted averages if you
look at a company a company is a
collection of projects right you have
project one project two project three if
you take the weighted average concept
every project has a
beta so one of your projects is a
contract with the
government the beta might be close to
zero so if you take pel and two
businesses right one with the government
one with commercial businesses the beta
for the government business will might
be lower the margins might be lower as
well each project has a
beta so if I asked you to estimate the
beta for Disney and you take every
single project this is going to be a
nightmare every movie is a project I
mean think of the hundreds and hundreds
of project so to make this manageable
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
bundle projects together based on the
business all the movies go to the movie
business you want to break it out to
action movies and animated movies you
can do that but you want to bundle you
do this because otherwise you face this
really impractical problem of getting
betas for projects so today what we're
going to do is we're going to break
companies down by businesses and build
up to a beta for the company from those
business betas lots of estimation
questions along the way but I'm going to
offer this as an alternative and argue
that this is a much better way of
estimating a beta for a company than
running a single regression taking the
slope of the line and saying that's a
beta for my
company so let's take a look at the
process we're going to go through I want
somebody to remember Ravi you can be my
guinea pig start a company and you can
get into any two businesses you want
pick two
businesses AI is not a business so let's
be very clear right AI so tell me what
kind of AI are you going to do is it's
going to be entertainment AI or it's
going to be business a so ship maker so
you're going to be an architect so
basically you're going to build the AR
so you're going to go up against Nvidia
you're going to make AI chips and
tobacco okay good very different
businesses say I'll be back to so people
are saying that's a strange combination
hey why not you smoke and then you make
AI chips right it could be cannabis and
AI that could be a lot worse or alcohol
and AI in which case I don't know what
chips you're making you know maybe it's
potato chips and you're selling them as
AI chips so here's what I'm going to do
to get the beta for revy's company I'm
going to go back to my office or to my
computer I'm going to find as many
publicly traded chip companies as I can
I might not be able to find AI chip
companies there aren't enough that call
them but there are lots of semiconductor
chip companies let's say there are 50 of
them and I'm going to find as many
publicly traded tobacco companies as I
can 100 of them around the world
world they're publicly traded what can I
get for each of them a beta right so I
can get a beta for each company I'm
going to average the beta for the air
chip companies and average the beta for
the tobacco companies s in there now
have an average beta for a tobacco
company and an average beta for a chip
company those are regression betas right
when you average a regression beta you
get a beta with leverage and I don't
know whether Ravi chooses to use debt or
not in his that's a choice so to take
out the effective debt I'm going to
unlever the two
betas what I'm going to end up with is
an unlevered beta for being in the
tobacco business and an unlevered beta
for being in the chip business then I
come back to RI and say look you told me
you were in two businesses tell me how
much of your value you get from each and
his reaction might be I don't know how
much value I get but I can tell you how
much revenue I get let's start with that
right it's it might not be perfect it's
not value but let's say you get 75% of
your revenues from chips and 25% from
tobacco I take a weighted
average I now have an UNL baa for R's
company I ask him a final question do
you have any debt if he says no I'm done
that unlevered bait is now the levered
bait of requ equity because but if he
does have debt I'm going to compute a
debt to equity ratio and relever the
beta up so this word unlever and relever
pick your own words for what we're doing
we're taking out the effect of Deb and
bringing it back in but now we're
bringing in rav's choice to come up with
the debt to equity and the lever
beta I now have a beta for the equity in
R's company why am I doing all of this
because I don't like regression betas
right but where did I get the 100
tobacco the 100 Tobacco Company betas
and the 50 chip company betas I got them
from
regressions so what is the advantage of
using an average of a 100 regression
betas instead of using a single
regression
beta think back to statistics
class remember the law of large
numbers what do the law law of large
numbers say you can take a 100 crappy
numbers put them in a pot stir them up
and pull the average out and it's
magically precise I never got this in my
statistics class I think I get it now
when we say that a beta has a high
standard error we're saying some of the
betas that we're estimating are too high
some are too low when I average aage out
I average out my mistakes the beta that
I get by averaging a 100 regression
betas is going to be 10 times more
precise 10 times more precise than a
single regression
beta how do I come up with 10 I make up
some stuff as I go along but 10 I did
not have to make up how did I get the 10
the square root of the 100 I four 50 AI
chip companies right I take the average
of the that's going to be about seven
times more precise roughly because 49
take the square root what if I have only
25 still five times more precise what if
I have only nine it's still three times
more precise anything beats
one the bottom of beta basically allows
you to make your beta estimate more
precise it's also more proactive more
forward-looking in what sense if Ravi
entered the Airship business yesterday
he was a tobacco company and he decided
a lot of cash flows in tobacco it's a
shrinking business we're going to go
into different business there is zero
chance a regression beta of his returns
would reveal that right because I'm
looking at the last 5 years but when I
pick the weights I'm picking them based
on the business he's in today in fact I
can be proactive and say what other
businesses do you plan to be in in the
next five years and if he says software
I'm going to add a third component I
retain control of this process and
reflect it to see changes in your
company so if you think about this
process what do I need for to do this
for a real company first I need to get
the answer that I got from R what
businesses are you in do companies break
themselves down by
business they have to accounting
requires that we get more than 10% and
some of the ways they break it up are
kind of weird and when you see Disney
you're going to see what I mean but but
they do break themselves down they're
required
to so I'm going to start with that I
have to find the unlevered beta for each
business so then I have to find publicly
traded companies in each space
and with Disney you're going to see the
challenges I face and I'm going to make
it real I'm going to tell you the
problems I ran into in trying to come up
with an UNL beta for Disney's businesses
and the two Pathways I use to get around
those problems and I run into them
because you might have to use this for
your company when you get the beta so
let me
start with Disney's breakdown in
2013 this is how Disney broke themselves
down into businesses if you don't like
the way they broke it down it's not not
my fault I'm just taking what they did
as a breakdown and these are the five
businesses they told me they were in the
first is what they called media networks
you know what was in
there all the broadcasting businesses
ABC Disney
cable and I think that a piece of star
India little so all the broadcasting
businesses they report and this is this
was nice because many companies don't
report anything beyond revenues Disney
broke down revenues operating income
depreciation Abid GNA so it's a nice
breakdown because they've broken down
everything for every business so that's
your first business the second business
of
course is a business we all recognize
right it's the original Disney business
not really it's a second Disney business
the original Disney business of course
was animated movies last uh last Friday
my son works at Disney and I had to you
know waiting for something so I went
into the office is with them and he took
me for a tour around the Disney Burbank
building and he showed me the building
that Snow White built the original
building with the dwarfs holding them up
Snow White provided the money to do all
of Disney so it's a company that started
with one movie the revenues from that
movie gave birth to the entire company
them parks and resorts of course
includes
Disneyland Disney World Euro Disney and
Tokyo Disney are kind of strange
beings because Disney doesn't actually
own them it runs them it gets a
management fee and now in in
2013 no Shanghai hadn't opened but Hong
Kong was in the verge of opening but
these are the theme parks and resorts in
addition Disney threw Cruise
Lines into this grouping I told you
companies do things you got to take them
for what they worth their argument is
nobody gets on a Disney cruise unless
you want to see Mickey and if you're
seeing Mickey it's coming out of the
theme parks hey see the logic here
that's theme parks and Resorts then you
got Studio entertainment those are
Disney's movie businesses in
2013 there was Marvel there was Pixar
and there was Disney this used to have
Touchstone mirror Max you know luckily
they escaped the Miramax course because
before Harvey one ended up in all kinds
of trouble but they originally owned all
of those companies but this were the the
the the three movie companies then you'd
consume a products there was a time when
Disney had a very extensive retail
business there's still a Disney Store on
Time Square now there are like a few
dozen used to be 600 Disney Stores they
pulled out of that they used to make
their own products they don't do that
anymore it's become a licensing business
so Disney doesn't make any of its own
stuff it licensed it's a very different
business model right because you don't
have to deal with the manufacturing and
all of the issues with it you collect a
licensing fee so it's a consumer product
business and in 20133 Disney created a
business called interactive with Big
Dreams because this is the height of
computer gaming and they thought they
could get into it five different
businesses so my task is laid out for me
right what do I have to do I have to go
find publicly traded companies in each
of these spaces as I said I'm going to
keep this real because I'm going to take
you through the the barriers that I ran
into the walls and how I got around them
the first place was I want wanted to
find broadcasting businesses when you
think about broadcasting companies in
the
US four four names come to mind right
ABC CBS NBC and
fox and here's the problem in 2013 ABC
was owned by Disney CBS I think was
still owned by Westing
/ge I'm sorry NBC was owned by G and you
couldn't even find it within G CBS was
owned by Westinghouse and fox was owned
by News Corp company that is so opaque
you have no idea what it
owns already you can see getting a clean
line on a Broadcasting Company was
really difficult I was desperate what do
you need for the law of large
numbers large numbers I'm at zero right
here so here's my first Ploy I said if I
cannot find companies that do what my
company does I'm going to go up and down
the stream of companies that feed into
the business and I'm going to include
those companies as companies in my peer
group so I'll give you a couple of
examples of companies that that I
included in my broadcasting
business one is the company that
actually Syndicate syndicates the Oprah
show so it's a it's a show that derives
its revenues from syndicating TV shows
and I said if you Syndicate TV shows
you're going to do well when
broadcasting companies do well and badly
when you do badly I included neelon a a
company that basically rates TV shows
but again is attached very close so
essentially my objective was to go up
and down the food chain including
companies that feed into the food
chain if you cannot find let's say
you're valuing or analyzing a company
that does
Consulting for tourism that's all the
businesses and you can't find other
consulting firms there's no reason why
you can't look at tourism companies up
and down the Spectrum and include them
CU they're all affected by the same
macro
forces I 20 26 companies would I like
more 26 I can live with would I have
rather had 100 yes but 26 is good enough
and the unlevered baa and I I I'll take
you through the process of how how I do
this that I got was 1.03 13 I'll pick
one of these sectors and take you to the
mechanics of how I got the UNL beta but
I went through the process of getting
the regression betas cleaning them up
for debt and cleaning them also up for
the effects of cash sounds mysterious
for the moment but when a company has
cash its regression beta is going to get
pushed down I have to take out that
effect but have an UNL beta for the
broadcasting business as I said I'll
return and show you the mechanics of
that then I went to theme parks and
Resorts and I look for publicly traded
companies in this space and I very
quickly ran into a second
problem in the
US there were only two publicly traded
companies I could find one was Six Flags
which is a basket case company a huge
debt ratio in the verge of disaster the
others is Midwestern Cedar something
something company which is again a small
but two companies is not helping me very
much so here I decided to go a different
way I went
Global I said why do I have to stay us
focused you're saying but you can't
compare betas across countries why not
what's the average beta across all us
companies it's one the average bet
across All European companies one
African companies one Asian companies
one Bas don't carry the taint of country
risk so when I went Global I ended up
with about 20 amusement park companies
around the world so they included
companies like Legoland the company that
own Legoland publicly traded and
included in the space again I went
through the process get the regression
betas average them out clean them out
and come up with the non-lit beta yes R
getting betas for those global companies
are those the that's that's good
question and I think that's that's a
very good estimation question right
because when you go look it up on
Bloomberg for each of these companies
what are you getting what did I say
Bloomberg does it runs a regression a
very parochial way it runs a regression
against the local index and ravi's
question is did I take those betas you
know the law of large numbers does for
you it's very
forgiving if you have large samples and
you have betas against different indices
each might be screwed up by that index
choice right right sometimes it might be
too high because the index is too narrow
sometimes it's going to be too low and
as with everything else in the law of
large numbers you can afford to be
sloppy so if you have 25 30 50 companies
you can afford to run it against a Lo if
you have six or seven or eight this
decision becomes much more significant
weekly or monthly what index should I
use and there the argument is maybe you
should pick a common index a global
Equity index to rerun them but then
you'd have to rerun the regressions
yourself you can't pull out the betas
from
blo and I went to the movie business and
that's the business I'm going to focus
on I found publicly traded movie
companies in the US and the US happens
to be one of the few countries where
movie businesses are actually publicly
traded much of the rest of the world
they're either privately owned or parts
of much bigger
businesses the unlit bait and I that's
the one that I'm going to focus on and
take you through but let me finish this
table and then I'll take the studio
entertainment and blow it up consumer
products lots and lots of companies
mostly I took game toy companies 44
companies as the unloved beta and
finally interactive I looked at Global
computer gaming companies and there were
33 companies and I came up so if you
look at the last column those are my
estimated betas of being in the business
this are called Pure Play betas you're
trying to estimate a beta for a business
so as I as I promised I'm going to take
one business the studio entertainment
business because it's nice and compact
and take you through the mechanics of
how to get the bait I don't know whether
you checked your email late last
night and there was a very scary
attachment that came with it he said
what there's been a case on the calendar
for a while some of you might have been
aware of it most of you probably didn't
even know there was a case I attached
the case to that email yesterday so if
you haven't if you trash that email go
pull it out of the trash you actually
don't have to the case is on on a on on
my web page anyway and the case is about
doing an investment project one of the
things you have to do is come up with
the cost of capital for the project the
exercise I'm going to go through is
going to be very similar to the exercise
you will have to go through perhaps for
that project as well so if there's any
mechanical step that you have trouble
with make me stop and go over it because
I want to make sure everybody gets
it so here's the entertainment business
the the the first call these are all
mostly smaller and movie companies you
see why they're going to be smaller
because the minute you become larger
you're going to bring in other
businesses in by staying with smaller
companies So you you're not seeing if
you look across the list very I mean the
largest companies here I think are you
know uh lion gate and DreamWorks in 21st
Century Fox you don't see Warner
Brothers up there because it also has
other businesses so I've got the the
publicly traded companies I looked up
the regression beta so I call it a lever
beta to remind myself it's a regression
beta it's lever I need to clean it up
second column is the market cap market
cap is just a market value of equity
share price times number of shares again
it's public information then I've total
debt including leases remember this was
2013 when accountants were doing strange
things with leases reading is operating
I converted leases debt we'll talk more
about why we do that and how we do that
but there's the total debt so up till
there all I'm doing is pulling up public
information those are those are three
pieces of data you can get for any
company that's publicly
traded if you add up the market cap and
the total debt you get What's called the
value of the entire firm but some of
that firm value comes from
cash and I'm going to take out the
effective cash from The Firm value and I
do that I get what's called Enterprise
Value the the best way to think
intuitively about Enterprise values this
is what the market is valuing a
company's operating assets at the firm
value includes the cash as well so when
you look at a company like apple if I
took the smartphone business the
computer business and the services
business the Enterprise Value captures
the value of that but then you have a
$200 billion cash balance on
top so so far all I'm doing is pulling
numbers of them in the last few columns
you basically see the the extra data I
pulled up I've called pulled up the
pre-tax cost to debt and the marginal
tax rate but I compute what's called
what I'm going to call a gross debt to
equity ratio I'll just call it a debt to
equity I take the total debt and divide
by the market cap not by the book value
of equity but by the market Gap and you
can see the debt to equity ratio all
over the place now if you this are a
statistics class what are the two
numbers on that column that jump out at
you is a 4.77% debt to equity ratio and
a 5.51% debt to equity ratio and when
you average and you got these two really
big outliers you know what that's going
to do to the average it's going to pull
the average up you're saying so what if
I take that average debt to equity
strange things are going to happen to my
UNL pom so go back to your sta
statistics class if you have a
distribution where outliers are pushing
in One Direction if they're in both
directions they average out but in One
Direction they're pushing it out I don't
know about you but I was told in my
statistics class to look at the median
the median is the middle of the exact
halfway through so I've got the average
and the median I also compute an
aggregated number what's the aggregated
number I add up the debt for all of the
companies add up the equity for all of
the companies it's a neat way to get rid
of outliers especially if they're small
companies which they usually are it's
like a weighted average so I've got a
simple average a weighted average and a
median number and I have it for the beta
I have it for the debt to equity and I
also have it for how much cash these
companies have as a personal value for
the moment kind of hold on to that b the
regression bait is 1.24 these companies
have about 3% cash out of the firm value
and a debt to equity ratio of 27% I'm
going to work with the
medians because I think the I could use
the aggregated values as well you're
going to get a very similar number but
I'm going to work with the medians
because I think they're more meaningful
here so what do I have to do I have to
use these numbers to come up with an
unlevered for the studio business
yes that's that's a good question which
is you could unlever each company's beta
right it's using its debt to equity
ratio it's a purely statistical reason
when you have noisy numbers doing
operations with noisy numbers creates
even noisier numbers now it sounds like
I'm talking some Greek but what I'm
basically talking about is you have a
debt to equity ratio that's 500 600% use
it to unlever the regression beta for
that company you're actually pushing it
further away from the truth so whenever
you have noise it's better to average
out first and the bonuses it's quicker
to do you're not doing 11 UNL betas or
10 UNL betas you're doing it once with
the aggregated
numbers so I have a regression beta
1.24 cash is 3% of value and the debt to
equity ratio is 27% first let's get a
sense of direction regression beta is L
beta 1.24 right but I have a debt to
equity ratio of 27 % so what will my
unlevered Beta look like lower than 1.24
or higher than
1.24 the Lev beta includes the effective
debt I'm going to take out the effective
debt so to make my UNL beta lower right
so I'm going to get an unlit beta for
the company that was my first step I
took out the debt to equity ratio effect
so that's the same equation you saw last
session when I took Disney's regression
beta and cleaned it up the unlevered
beta that I come up with for being in
the movie business is about
1.07 so that's the unlit beta for a
typical movie
company but a typical movie company's
97% movie business 3%
cash you think so what what's a beta of
cash it's zero that 3% cash is pulling
down the beta and I want to take out the
effective cash because I want to just
get a beta for the movie business so
it's a pure algebra problem 97% is movie
business 3% is Cash I'm solving for the
beta for the movie business and that
movie business bait is going to be
higher than 1.06 and I want the
intuition to be clear you take out the
effect of cash the rest of the business
has to be riskier that's what you saw as
the unlevered beta for this business
it's a pure play beta it's basically a
beta for being the movie
business so if you look at my Beta
averages by sector you'll see this beta
corrected for for cash it always throws
people off maybe I need to come up with
a better description of it but that's
exactly what I'm doing in every Industry
Group I want to get as pure a beta as I
can for the business you're in and I did
this for all five businesses let me
pause right there because there lot
coming at you in terms of
numbers but think of the sequence you
start with the regression beta it's
lever beta you first take out the effect
of debt because you don't want it in
there and then you say look there's cash
in there there's a shortcut that some
people use especially in Europe and
Latin America instead of going through
this two-step process what's the
shortcut of using the gross debt to
equity ratio and adjusting for cash what
could I do
instead
Constantin what if I took the debt and
netted cash out from it you get a net
debt ratio if you ear lever using a net
debt ratio you're going to get an answer
very similar to one you're saying why
don't you do it because I feel more
comfortable cleaning up for debt first
and then adjusting for cash cuz cash
could be here today gone tomorrow so
from that perspective you want to use a
net debt ratio you're going to get
roughly the same answer because you're
doing in one step what I do in
two so now I have five businesses and
UNL betas for the five what is the next
Once I had that for uh rby what did I
come back and ask him how much value do
you get in each business right say I
want you to go back to Disney and say
how much value do you get may go go back
to how they broke their businesses down
do you see a value column there there
revenues operating income
AB companies don't break down divisions
by value because divisions don't trade
you can't value you can hire somebody to
Value the business but that's going to
be an estimate these are accounting
numbers so what you have for these
businesses is a bunch of accounting
variables I have to convert if if I'm in
a hurry I would use those those counting
variables to weight things but here's
the reason you got to be cautious about
waiting for instance based on revenues
I'm treating a dollar in revenue from
the theme park business is worth roughly
the same as a dollar in revenue from the
consumer product business the the movie
business the broad and that's not going
to be true if margins are very different
across businesses if I could somehow
convert my Revenue number into an
estimated
value I'd be closer to the truth
right so let me go back to the previous
two pages ago you see the last column I
took the Enterprise Value that I got for
each of these companies and divided by
the revenue for each company the median
number that I got was 3.05 saying what
does that even mean movie businesses at
least you look on the on average trade
for about $3 3.05 times revenu if you
have a billion dollars in revenues the
market attaches a value of 3.0 5
billion you see what the next step I'm
going to do is I'm going to take the
revenue Disney gives me for each
business I'm going there's a 3.05 you
saw from that table I do that for the
other businesses so if you look across
businesses the consumer product business
is the least valuable in terms of
scaling revenues you don't make enough
money so it's 83 times the revenues but
team Parks broadcasting all of about
three but interactive gaming is low
perhaps because it's riskier the grow
grow might be more difficult to
deliver multiplying the revenues by that
multiple gives me an estimated value for
each of the five
businesses you add those estimated
values up you come up with the total
value for Disney's operating businesses
of 135 billion some of you might have
heard analyst use this term some of the
parts valuation it looks deep and
intense and that they did some serious
work this is all they've done they've
taken some Metric for each business
applied multiple to it revenues ebit die
ebit and they come up with the number
they add the numbers up and they act
like they spend three days they might
have actually spent three days to get to
that number but they should I mean this
is a this is a back this is the kind of
some of the parts valuation you do after
a long dinner where you've had too much
to drink and somebody says can you value
Disney you pull up the numbers you apply
a multiple to it you add the numbers I'm
I'm done it's a very sloppy some of the
parts but I can live with it for what
I'm doing which is to come up with a B
data for Disney as a company and based
on my assessment Disney is about 49%
broadcasting about 34% theme parks about
13% movies about 2% consumer
products and about 1.3% interactive
products the Only Rule is the weights
have to add up to
100% you take the weighted average mind
Lev betas I have an unlevered beta for
Disney as a company so this is where I
was with Ravi with the two businesses I
now have it for Disney it was a lot more
work to get there because there were in
five businesses was tough to find the
comparable
companies but this 9239 is the unlevered
bait of a Disney's operating
businesses does Disney have as a company
have cash yes it does if I wanted to get
an UNL beta for the entire company I
would take the UNL beta I have for the
the operating businesses weighted by the
value the operating businesses take the
beta for cash which is zero and weighted
by cash so if I really wanted to come up
with an UNL beta for Disney as a company
which I usually don't need for a cost of
capital purpose I can get there by
bringing the cash in
yes Enterprise Value and the value of a
company right so basically the value of
the business is kind of an a morphous
term firm value is the value of the
entire company right you take apple as a
company
the value of the entire company includes
the 200 billion in cash why because the
company has the cash but if I said what
is the value of Apple's operating
businesses you're going to subtract
other the cash that's Enterprise Value
so when people talk about Enterprise
Value that's why you net cash out
because you're trying to get an estimate
of how much the operations of the
company are being valued by the market
right and know when you get a chance go
through the steps they're not complex
but they're you know You' got to go
through sequentially you try to jump
steps you try to do things in a hurry
you can mess up so you know if you have
your company already and you want to use
your company as an example to to get
ready for the quiz it's a great way to
kill two birds with one stone you can
get your project done and get ready for
the quiz by working with those weights I
now have an unlit B for the company at
9239 what's my last step when to ask
Disney do you have any debt and Disney
does have dead it has about 15.7 billion
but here's the challenge I face
Disney tells me how much debt they have
as a company but they don't break their
debt down by division you're saying why
not because they don't have
to and the money is fungible the company
goes out and borrows money so you look
at the
balance so I don't have debt by division
the first edition of this book that I
wrote I got to this point say Disney
doesn't break the debt down by
division I don't know what the debt is
by division so I'm going to take
Disney's debt to equity ratio and make
it the debt to equity ratio for each of
its businesses sloppy lazy but that was
my excuse they don't break but we know
that some of these businesses carry more
debt than
others so I know the last know after the
first I tried to start allocating the
debt you're based on what in this case
I've allocated debt based on what Disney
calls its identifiable assets which are
barely physical fixed assets why did I
do this because lenders like to lend
money on fixed fix assets so if you're a
business without a lot of fixed asset my
assumption is you can't borrow a great
deal and I end up with Deb to equity
ratios that are very different across
the five businesses so the total debt
I've taken and allocate it based on the
assets across the businesses I also
allocated the equity that Disney has
across the businesses because basically
once I know the value of the debt I can
subtract it from the estimated value of
each business and have a debt to equity
ratio I'm almost there right I've got an
unlevered beta for each business I have
a debt to equity ratio I apply the debt
to equity ratio on the unlevered
business I come up with a levered ba for
each business it's a long journey but
there's a reason why this is so critical
if you're a multi-bus company because
you have different lever bers you have
different cost of equity and if you
believe my numbers the cost of equity
for Disney's operations collectively is
8.52% but the cost of equity varies
anywhere from 7.09% for theme parks to
almost 11.6% for interactive
gaming I now have a cost of equity for
the company and cost of equity for each
of the five divisions but I was able to
do it because I had I can't do this with
the regression beta there is no
regression beta for interactive gaming
there's no so this is a this is
something you can do if you break a
business down and build up its cost of
equity any questions to the mechanics
you look a little
dazed it'll pass right so let's say you
got the mechanics nailed down and you
will you know if you take it you've now
become the CFO of Disney you're sitting
in your Burbank
office and I'm going to be the movie guy
why because I want the fun
job I come into your office I barge in
movie guys never knock they barge in
said we're planning a big budget movie
you're getting ready to throw me out
because you know exactly what happens
after I plan a big budget moving Lone
Ranger
2 this time without Johnny
Depp Lone Ranger one was one of the big
fiascos of all time $200 million budget
made 35
million but this time we're doing it
right so what do you mean so we've hired
five mbas to work through the numbers
and they've come up with the return on
equity for the movie no movie guy talks
like
this return in equity is kind of a
foreign language to them but the MB have
taught me the RO so I said return and
Equity I don't even say return Equity I
say Roe the the abbreviation always
sounds more sophisticated of
99.5% so you're the CFO you're in charge
of the
checkbook you have to decide whether to
fund the movie what's the question you
have to ask is 99.5% a high enough
return in equity to take the project
right
you know why I picked 9.5% it's higher
than the cost of equity for the
company but it's lower than the cost of
equity for the movie business so really
the the the choice I I'm asking you to
make is when you decide on this project
should you be comparing to the cost of
equity for the company which comes up
with the money or should you be
comparing it to the cost of
equity of the business
that the project is in Derek what do you
think in fact let let let's open up how
many of you think you should use the
company's cost of equity because the
company comes up with the money and
therefore if it beats that cost of
equity you should take the project okay
Yousef
Constantine so we have a few so you know
Yousef I'm going to put you on the spot
right so let's say you decide to do this
so every business now gets an 8 and a
half% cost of equity right
which of the five businesses is going to
be happy that you did this and which
ones are going to be
disappointed they're going to be happy
what are you asking them to do use a
higher cost you remember when you use a
higher cost of equity you're not going
to be able to take as many projects so
they're a safe business you're putting a
higher cost of equity on them than they
would have faced otherwise they're going
to be the most unhappy of the group you
know who's going to be dancing in the
streets the interactive gaming people
they say this is amazing we're part of
the Disney
Family let's play it out though so what
will this mean there'll be fewer theme
parks built probably none a lot of
interactive gaming things because you
beat it over time what's going to happen
to Disney as a company its safest
businesses will shrink and its riskiest
business will not just grow but they
will overgrow they are taking bad
projects why because they're being
subsidized by the safe businesses
over time those businesses that
subsidize will shrink and go away there
was a reason Bankers Trust started the
1980s it's a Commercial Bank and by the
end time you got to 1990 Bankers Trust
had become almost entirely an investment
bank because they played the stupid game
of which business has a higher return
Equity we'll put our money in it
Commercial Banking couldn't compete with
Investment Banking was much safer so
over time it kept getting sub kept
subsidizing until it disappeared
half of all global companies do this
they talk about a corporate cost of
equity and capital and that's a
terrifying term because a minute you say
corporate cost of equity and capital it
becomes this discount ready apply across
the board you're in 26 businesses you
apply one corporate cost of capital I
will safely predict what your company is
going to look like five years from now
it's not going to be
good first rule in capital budgeting and
investment analysis is the discount rate
for a project should reflect the risk of
the project and in this case the risk of
the business is standing in for that
rather than the risk of the entity
looking at the project you could be the
safest company in the face of the Earth
but you're entering the AI business
tobacco company is it really
safe but if Ravi took the cash from the
tobacco company and he's going to the AI
chip business and he uses the same cost
of capital for two it's not fair it's
not right cu the toac e business cost of
capital should be low and the cost of
and this process allows you to come up
with different hurdle
rates so if you if if it's that simple
it's the first principle saying how come
so many
companies violate that principle what do
you think the reason is that so many
companies use a corporate cost of
capital as a discount rate across the
board it's it's easier in what s risk
cre Equity risk premium are going to be
there
anyway you need a beta how do they Kelly
how do they get a
beta they go to Bloomberg they look up
the beta and they get a regression beta
for a company for the company right
there is no regression beta for theme
parks bro if the way you get a beta is
from a regression you are trapped
there's only one beta for the
company so even if you don't buy into
any of my other Arguments for a bottom
of beta this argument alone should be
sufficient say I'm going to build up to
a beta for a company based on the
business it's in because it's in very
different
businesses so it's one of the first
principles in corporate finance gets
violated all the time so one is the fact
that they get a regression beted the
other is it creates some internal
tension within the company I'll give you
an example about 30 years ago now
student from my this class had gone on
to work at the Gap and the Gap at that
time was just a gap there were every
store was a Gap
store and they then introduced two new
variants on the Gap one was Banana
Republic which is Gap Clos marked up by
30% but you don't have to deal with the
Riff
Raff lot of empty stores and the other
was Old Navy which is Gap stores
discounted by 30% and lots of Riff Raff
so three different businesses
so he calls me after this plan and he
say you know he says I remember the
corporate finance class and I was
thinking through what the H because at
that time they used an 18% hurdle rate
for their Gap
stores don't even ask me how they came
up with the 18% but that was their
hurdle rate and as long as every store
was a Gap Store 18% work so he was in
the finance group and he was thinking
about know these new divisions are
opening so you can help him out if 18%
is a hurdle rate for a Gap store and you
think about Old Navy Gap banana Republic
think discretionary non-discretionary
tolu which one of these should have the
highest higher hurdle
rate Banana Republic because in a sense
you charge higher prices much higher
margins and Old Navy because it
discounts should have so and he talked
through this and I said you know he said
I I think I'm going to push in this
meeting for having a higher hurdle rate
for you know for the Banana Republic a
much lower hurdle rate I knew exactly
the saw he was going to walk into but I
didn't want to let him Anno I said tell
me what happens after the meeting so he
calls and he says it did not go well I
said what happened he said one of the
divisional heads did not like the idea
at all I said let me guess was it the
Banana Republic guy he said yeah he
really didn't like the idea at
all I said what did the CEO do he said
the CEO for the moment thinks of the the
Banana Republic as one of his star
divisions he doesn't want to to rock the
boat so for the moment we're going to
continue to use 18% hurdle rates across
the company because introducing
different hurdle rates requires that you
put your foot down you're a risky
business you should be earning a higher
return and if that risky business is
your high growth business and that
person pushes back they think i' to be
willing to take a stand you know one of
the worst culprits on this is
Banks there was a time when if you
looked at a bank it did banking things
what are banking things you take
deposits you lend them out you make
money on the
spread and starting in the 80s what did
Banks do non-banking things real estate
trading Investment Banking all exciting
high
growth but if you were sensible in the
bank as you entered these new businesses
you should be saying look we have
limited Equity if we're investing it in
these riskier business we should be
demanding a higher hurdle rate but not
one of them did that so over time what's
happened to every single bank that enter
these spaces the non-banking side has
essentially overwhelmed the banking side
until you hit a
crisis
right so when you're into risky
businesses you need to set the threshold
higher because it's not because you're
being greedy but because you're being
prudent so let's yeah go ahead so I get
my companies have multiple line of
business but let's just say there's a
company that has one line of let's take
one so give it let's make it specific
give me an
example it's one bus yeah but would you
still need a bottom up beta even though
you're in one business would you still
be able to need a bottom up beta even
though you're in one business yeah why
because there the are the r you don't
need multiple business betas you don't
need to be proactive what's the
advantage you get with a bottom of beta
for restaurant instead of using the
Shake Shack beta uh
it's just still that law law of large
numbers so even in a single business you
still will use bottom up AAS and if
Shake Shack at what some point in time
decides to go with a lower price version
let's face face it Shake Shack is more
upscale it kind of is in the big cities
it's not it's not a McDonald's it's not
an in andout it's not a you know if it
decides to go with maybe a lower cost
version which is an opening you will be
in a position to say you can't apply the
corporate cost of capital you been using
so far let's talk about ways in which
you can estimate the b or it could go
upscale so we're going to introduce you
know there are high price burger joints
$50 a burger we're going to go after
that market and it might be a much more
niche market you're ready in case that
happens because at some point in time
it's company scale up whether they like
it or not they often have to look beyond
the business because that's how you
continue to grow okay any other any
other
questions
yeah I'm going to now try to get a
bottomup beta for
Val Val is in four businesses again I
took this right off there financials now
first two are mining businesses one
metals and Mining and the second is Ion
or they're fundamental businesses and
ior they started as an i or company that
remains a heart of their company but
they have two other businesses one is a
fertilizer business and the and the
other is a logistics business they gave
me the revenues for each business and I
did exactly what I did for Disney so I
went Bor with the details of one thing
is when I computed the averages I used
Global averages not just Brazilian
company averages why because if you
think the law of large
numbers you know is is is is an issue
and and it's a with us companies you're
always going to find enough sample even
if you stay us Centric you go to Brazil
you go to Portugal you're going to get
much smaller samples if you say country
Focus so even bigger need for Global and
the other is these are mining businesses
mining business is it doesn't really
matter whether you're a Brazilian mining
company or Australian Mining Company
what do they do they extract stuff out
of the ground and they sell it into a
global market that's a dollar based
Market an oil company no reason to stay
focused on Latin American oil companies
or European oil companies so you notice
I use Global for oil form sample size
varies widely for the fertilizer
business where I used specialty chemical
there are 693 publicly traded companies
this is overkill right I mean think
about the the savings you're going to
get with 693 companies but since I have
them might as well use them I came up
with the UNL beta for these businesses
just like I did for the studio business
if I had to do this by hand I would
restrict my sample size to 10 or 15 or
20 if you're doing it in Excel what
difference does it make so I use median
numbers for all of them I take a
weighted average based again on the
estimated value the business and based
on my estimates it looks like V is about
76% iron or but 177% mining but 5%
fertilizers and 2% Logistics gain the
weights add up to 100% I have an unloved
beta for Vol as a company of
844 here again I can estimate a cost of
equity for each business and I chose to
do my assessment entirely in US Dollars
even though it's a Brazilian company why
was
that it's a commodity company commodity
companies actually around the world off
and Report their financials in dollars
because they live in a dollar based
world right so it's not because I was
trying to be dollar Centric here I said
look you I could have done it in RS but
it's actually better to do it it's
easier to do it in dollars so my risk
free rate is the T bond rate the equity
risk premium if you you know it's been a
while back was the weighted average of
where b gets its revenues and I have a
cost of equity in dollar terms for each
of the businesses and for Val as a
company so what does that mean you know
you can see my cost of equity for
fertilizers is going to be higher than
my cost of equity Logistics but notice
that the differences are smaller across
the businesses here you could get away
with using a corporate cost hurdle rate
but it's by
accident so if you're in businesses that
are very similar to each other your BHP
and every business you have is a variant
on a mining business you might be able
to get away with a corporate cost of
capital but it's only because of that
accidental closeness they have to each
other I did give them all the same debt
to equity ratio because they're all
infrastructure businesses they all need
big Investments up front there's nothing
that stood out and said you know what
maybe I should think about a different
debt to equity ratio because it is a bit
of a mess allocating debt across
businesses and you saw that with
this let's say I do this I take it up to
my managing director
and he's a pain in the neck he says I
don't want anything in dollars I want
everything in
R God I went through all this work hey
don't worry it's actually very simple to
convert a dollar rate into a r rate and
if you remember how we did this with
risk free rates all you have to do is
bring in the differential inflation so
all I did was I took the cost of capital
I had in dollar terms 11.23% for the
company estimated expected inflation in
Brazil and the US 9% and 2% % and
there's my re cost of capital
18.87% could I have done it by going
back to a REI risk free rate yes the
answers might not match but I could take
the government bond rate and re subtract
out the risk free rate essentially make
your choice if you want to pick a
currency and you come up with the cost
of capital and if you want to switch
currencies just to see if you can do it
try to do it in a different currency see
what the cost of capital would look
like last two companies start aut
Motors actually last three I started
with the beta for automobile companies
again I started Indian automobile
companies and I very quickly realized I
had a problem only three of them so I
went Global and especially with Jaguar
Land Rover becoming part of tarda Motors
I didn't see a need to stay Emerging
Market focused the UNL beta was 86 I did
briefly consider breaking T modus into
luxury automobiles and mass Market
automobiles
but in 2013 there weren't enough
publicly traded Luxury Auto companies
was a BMW maybe you could throw in
there today you can throw in Ferrari I
mean but that's a very
different business than any other Luxury
Auto Company so basically I left them as
an automobile company I came up with an
unlevered beta of 8601 and then I used T
Motors tax rate and T motor debt to
equity so the UNL beta comes from the
business for whatever business you're in
but your company's tax rate and your
company's Deb to equity ratio that gives
you a lever
beta here I did everything in rupee
terms there's my rupee risk free rate
there's my bottom of beta there's the
equity risk premium based on where they
operate
14.49% cost of equity in repeat terms
the way currency enters in is through
the risk R right it's not the beta it's
not the risk premium it's through the
risk
create any questions on the T Motors
and for Buu the levered beta that I get
is
1356 now based on the unlevered beta
being in the online advertising business
companies in that space they have very
little debt 5.23% debt to equity ratio
we'll talk about why they have so little
debt but clearly that's all they have
Lev beta 1.36 in rembe terms Yuan terms
the cost of equity is
12.91% risk free rate risk premium paid
so reminder again risk fre is a currency
Equity risk PR reflects where you
operate the beta reflects the business
you're in the bottom up beta is now
replacing the regression beta for each
of these
companies finally I looked at deutser
and I broke them down into two
businesses commercial and Investment
Banking I don't know why it does the
wrong thing but it should be the
commercial Investment
Banking Commercial Banking I looked at
Commercial Banking commercial Banks in
Europe for investment Banks I had to
look at Global investment Banks because
most European Investment Banking is
within the Commercial Banking arm so
it's only in the US you have Morgan
Stanley Goldman Stacks so I broke them
down to two businesses but here's the
difference and I want you to think about
why I took the average beta for
commercial Banks and the average beta
for investment Banks and I left them
what what's a step I'm skipping here
that I did for
the I didn't unle
and relever what do you think that
is what do I need for unlevering and Rel
Levering you need debt and debt for a
bank is an absolute
nightmare right I'm not even sure debt
to a bank is a source of capital it's
raw material right technically the
deposits you have in a bank are
debt and if you define that as debt God
help you right 97% debt 3% equity
so with banks what you do is you avoid
the Levering and unlevering is said
please God let The Regulators be doing
be doing the job because you're not
exactly going to getting all Equity
funded back they all borrow money they
borrow up to regulatory limits and
you're throwing up your hands and saying
I'm just going to take the lever bait
and I'm going to use it for my cost of
equity could it get into trouble yes
because if implicitly what am I assuming
all banks are equally
risky
right and one way you can start
separating that out is you can look at
at how over capitalized or under
capitalized a bank is maybe you can tie
the bank to regulatory capital and
whether they're doing it I don't want to
go there in this calculation so what you
get there is a bottom up beta for do the
only difference is I'm looking at the
levered betas and taking a weighted
average of the lever betas at the time
that I did this you know you can see the
breakdown of the two gave me much a
higher cost of equity which is what
you'd expect for investment banking than
Commercial Banking DOA wasn't doing this
in
and maybe that's part of the reason do
is in the trouble that it is now is it
let the investment banking arm
essentially run a Muk for a while and
after 2008 it's been trying to reain it
in but the damage has already been
done the reason you need to demand a
higher cost of equity for riskier
businesses there will be 2008 in your
risky
business and you have to be more
cautious in how you enter the business
because after the fact it's much too
late so let me I know it's I told you at
the start of the class I warned you that
a lot of stuff is coming at you so go
back and review the stuff that table
that I I'll fix that table because
basically that table that had the
holders should be really the table of
investment banking Commercial Banking
but if you know take a back and think
about a bank like JP Morgan right think
about the different business it's
in trading might be a separate business
investment banking might be a separate
business real estate might be a third
business and then think about how
different the hurdle rate should be
within that
business the last thing I want to talk
about today is getting a beta for a
private business I mean so far I've
talked about five of the six businesses
I said I was going to talk about in the
company right it's all publicly traded
but remember that six business I
mentioned at the start of the class that
I've kind of never gone back to
bookscape that privately owned bookstore
in New York City do they need a hurdle
rate yeah they have to make investments
too I'll tell you the story of how
bookscape ended up being in this
book long time ago owner of this
bookstore walks in I didn't have no idea
who she was she walks and say own this
bookstore and she gave me the name of
the bookstore I changed the name to kind
of know keep
it Anonymous and she said I've owned
this bookstore my grandfather St at the
bookstore we have a great location we
have good history but I'm facing an
existential
threat I'm say what do you talk to me
for she said a borders is opening this
is when borders was this high growth
bookstore a borders is opening down the
block from us and I'm faced with the
decision of either abandoning the
bookstore and get I'll get 2 million two
and a half million for because it's a
great lease the less all would pay me
two and a half million to go away
or staying and fighting I said what does
staying and fighting require she said
taking the rest of my wealth and putting
into the bookstore opening up a coffee
shop a restaurant the things that
borders has kind of up upscaling so I
said what are you talking to me for she
said I need to know what rate of return
she didn't use those terms specifically
I need to make on my investment to make
this exp she wanted a hurdle rate which
your question is how have you run a
bookstore for 50 years without a hurdle
rate
cuz you grandfather started the store
it's the right location you're not
exactly facing big investment decisions
right lots of private businesses can
Coast for a long time without ever
confronting the question of what do I
need to make now she was facing the
question she said can you help
me she gave me this $200 coupon to the
bookstore which I took you know I said
okay so here's what I did I went in know
so if you think about it what's the
challenge you face with a privately
owned business there's no regression bet
that's off the table I can try with
accounting earnings but that's a
mess but can I get a bottomup beta
for private book store what do I need
for a bottom of baa tell me what
business you're in so here's what I did
I went looking for publicly traded
companies in the book
space initially I looked at bookstores
but they're only about three or four so
I added publishing companies to the mix
and I looked up their regression base so
what you see on this page is very
similar to what I did for Disney pull up
the regression base
know unlever it clean up for cash came
up with an unlevered beta for being in a
bookstore business
7205 the you can you know that's
Overkill the fourth decimal point so 72
and of course we clean up for cash just
like we did for the studio business you
can come up with an un so far it looks
like I'm doing exactly what I do with
public
companies and I am the UNL beta is 76
now I run into the Second Challenge
what did I ask RI after I came up with
an nonl baate I asked him for a debt to
equity ratio but it's supposed to be a
market debt to equity ratio right for
Disney that wasn't a big deal there was
a market Equity number but this is a
privately owned bookstore he's saying
why not use book debt to equity that's
not even a choice God only knows what
book Equity measures but it definitely
is not a
competitor so what I did effectively was
I said look bookstores have a typical
debt ratio publicly traded bookstores
you're a bookstore the debt usually
takes the form of leases you probably
have a lease as well so I use the debt
to equity ratio of publicly traded
companies to lever up the beta so
already you can see if you're working
with a private business you can come up
with an unlevered beta but to get the
debt Equity you have to kind of look to
public companies again and that's what
I'm
doing I've actually tried calling
private business owners and say do you
have a Target debt to equity ratio and
the reaction is a what the kind of
answers the question now maybe if you're
a private business person and you said
my target debt to equity ratio is 25% I
can plug it in but I've almost never got
a usable answer when I asked that
question I ended up with a levit bait of
86 I'm almost there right risk free rate
plus beta times Equity risk premium I'm
doing things in dollars gives me a cost
of equity of
75% I almost called the lady to collect
my
coupon and give her this cost of equity
but then one big
problem with this cost eff Equity how do
how do I measure risk with the beta
right the capm derivation to use beta
what do you have to
assume that the marginal investor is
diversifi what did this lady say right
at the start of a pitch she said I'm
going to take the rest of my wealth and
put it in the books or this is the exact
opposite of being Diversified right so
I'm going to ask you an intuitive
question if 72% is the cost of equity
you demand as a diversified investor can
get rid of the
risk would you demand a higher cost of
equity or a lower cost of
equity should be higher right because
you have to bring in the rest of the
risk I remember running into this
question 30 years ago when I looked at
private business I looked everywhere
there was no people said just add an
extra 10% I said why because that's what
everybody does I said that doesn't work
for me so I went back to basics
let's think about it you have total risk
in a company let's say 100 units of risk
20 units of Market risk risk you cannot
diversify away and 80 are diversifiable
risk what do I capture with the beta I
capture the 20 units of Market risk I
assume the remaining 80 get Diversified
away I don't have that choice here I'm
not Diversified I'm going to be exposed
not just to the 20 but to the entire 100
units of risk you see what what I'm
going to try to do right I have the beta
if I can somehow scale it
to include the risk that is company
specific I'm going to come up with let's
call it a total beta that's a concoction
I came up with total because it captures
total risk why because you're exposed to
Total
risk say how in God's name am I going to
figure out how much of the risk in a
company comes from company specific risk
is there a number that we've looked at
already that tried to measure that
remember that Bloomberg progression page
there was a slope there was an intercept
what else was there an R SAR right what
are the r squ measure the percentage of
variation in the stock that is due to
the
market I publicly dated book
companies go back to two pages I the
last column I've collected their R
squares the average R squ across let's
say let's stick with the median the
median R squ is 26% 26% of the variance
in a typical book company comes from the
market the remaining 74% is company
specific and this person this owner is
going to be exposed to that 74% as well
so here's what I'm going to do I'm going
to take the market beta of 086 which I
got by doing the bottom of
beta and I'm going to divide it by the
square root of the r squ I'm going to
ask you a stupid question but kind of
human me what's the square root of R 2 R
which is a correlation so basically I'm
using the correlation why am I using
correlation purely statistical reason R
squs go with variance correlations go
with standard deviation beta is a
standard deviation measure and half the
standard deviation in the stock comes to
the market I end up with a beta
1.68 now I can use that beta because
that beta captures not just the market
risk but the rest of the risk in the
company
you plug it in you come up with the cost
of equity of
12%
11.98% 12% so I called her and I said
the hurdle rate is about 12% then she
asked me two questions one which was
which was easy to answer the second I
knew the answer to but I couldn't think
of a Kind way to give her the answer she
said borders is a publicly traded
company they're opening a store down the
block what will their cost of equity
look like what's what the answer to
that their investors are Diversified
they can get rid of firm specific risk
they're going to have a cost of equity
about 7 half per. I said that's then you
can see the second question coming right
she said if their cost of equity is 7
and a half% and my cost of equity is 12%
how the heck am I going to compete with
them over
time what the answer to the
question you
cannot so what's going to happen to
private business over time they're
essentially going to become public not
because private business people don't
work hard they might work much harder
than manages public companies but
because the way they're taking risk is
not efficient they're putting all their
wealth in it's all I mean if you think
about what's happened over the last 40
years and you look at businesses I'm old
enough to remember when you walked into
a pharmacy in the US the owner of the
pharmacy was usually behind the company
1980s today I challenge you to find an
independently owned Pharmacy in New York
City you walk do read this CVS's chains
that own it because over
time business after business this
happens and it's almost inexorable
you're almost not going to be able to
stop it from
happening now it's it's it's as you know
I'll tell you the levels to which it's
gone because the with especially with
the entry private Equity I grew up in a
part of um India Chennai where you know
where you had these small shopping areas
with the shopkeepers own their small
shops you'd go in last time I walked
down that area I haven't walked in a
long time I run it with shopkeepers been
around 40 years and I say hi to him and
he says you know and he's looking very
prosperous you know new outfit no stores
I said what happened he said I sold a
half my store to he gave the name a
private equity
private equities essentially come in
bought the half the business essentially
allowed him to cash out and half the
business and he's basically getting the
benefits of a diversified investor
willing to pay a higher price because or
in the form of rollups right lots of
businesses which start as private
businesses at one point in time every
video rental company was privately owned
and then came Blockbuster which rolled
up independent video rental stores to
make it into a chain
the last hold out was real estate real
estate for the longest time was you know
private developers and every city you
need localized knowledge but look at
real estate now the biggest real estate
owner in the US is Black
Rock why because they can compete
against private developers and they
don't care about localized risk it
averages out to them so Houston goes
down
7% but Los Angeles is up 5% you have a
portfolio you're a PR private developer
in one area you got to demand a higher
discount rate to reflect all those
concerns I know we have this sentimental
attachment to Mom and Pop stores and I
and I'd love to be able to deal with the
business the owners behind the counter
but even businesses like plumbing and
electri you know electric who you would
used to be privately owned increasingly
you're seeing that happen and it's
coming for
healthcare now one point in time you
walked into a doctor's office it was a
private practice the doctor owned the
practice today you pick a doctor they're
part of this chain that is part of a
bigger chain that's part of an even
bigger chain it's at the top is a
publicly traded company so the next time
you get pissed off at at something like
that happening it's coming from this
underlying problem of if you're not
Diversified you put all your wealth in
one business it's not so he's saying why
do people start businesses why do people
start Tech businesses what do they hope
what's the exit strategy there they
don't want to stay private they want to
take it public but do you do have people
who will start private businesses and
run it because they love running a
business I I I call it getting emotional
dividence you make only 11% from the
business you could have made 18% by
investing in a mutual fund of similar
it's your business you like being the
business and it works until you get to
be 75 years
old and you turn to your son or daughter
who's 45 would you like to run the
business they've noticed you running
ragged 16 hours a day for the no no no
I'm not interested when you get that
generational shift is often when you get
these private businesses
dissipate I'll tell you a story though
but um there used to be these auctions I
don't know whether you still have them
or faculty would give things to and what
what can we auction of other than
services so I offered to value a company
for somebody if they won the auction so
an MBA wins the auction he walks in I
expect a small business he's going to
ask me to Value it he comes with this
300 Pages document and I said I said
what business he said we're we're we're
a rum company in
Florida and we're a family-owned Rum
company I said that's interesting how
long have you been around he said about
years bakardi
right privately owned still why because
you drink enough of your product maybe
you don't care about diversifiable non-
diversifiable risk but you do get these
family businesses that last a long time
but they stay focused they stay small
and the owners say that's okay kogi
which is this
Japanese company lasted 1500 years but
they made they worked on Buddhist
shrines and that was their Core Business
they stayed in the core
business so essentially you do get
family businesses that stay privately
owned but they stay in a small small
Niche where no public company wants to
enter right I mean how big is a shrine
building business not like a big public
company enters a
space but you got to create a niche in a
sense if you're a private business where
you're okay with the fact that you might
not make as much money with that Capital
invested in some fund somewhere but
you're getting something else from
it so what I'd like you to do is take
your company look for that breakdown of
businesses this all presupposes again
that you picked a company I'm going to
not even ask you that question anymore
look at the breakdown of businesses you
might not do this until after the quiz
obviously the quiz becomes your first
priority for the moment know but take
your company break break it down by
business and sometimes you might face
challenges of what what are the
companies I should look at so the last
thing I will talk about is being
creative in your company choice I was uh
once asked to value a five star
restaurant in New York City by a friend
of a friend he said can you do this five
star restaurant was owned by a French
chef and it was being bought by this
publicly traded restaurant company
called Arc
restaurants so first Total bait is out
of the picture because you're selling to
a publicly traded company you should
just be looking at Diversified investors
in beta so it's not your diversification
that matters the buyers so he said can
you help me and I said okay know you
know he gave me the numbers in the
restaurant the number of you know
seatings he has Etc I learned more about
the restaurant Resturant business that I
ever wanted
to but then I go looking for publicly
traded restaurants and the list that I
look at I said this isn't going to work
for me because you pull a publicly you
get Chipotle you get McDonald's you get
Burger King you go to a French chef and
say here are your publicly traded pure
group he's not even to look at the rest
of the numbers how dare you compare me
to McDonald's right and it also doesn't
make sense who eats at a fstar
restaurant $250 for appetizer AR tray
and dessert not counting the wine only
two groups of people who have that much
money one is maybe billionaires on the
other is people spending other people's
money and within that group of people
who spend other people's money there you
have lawyers and
bankers you know what I did I used the
beta for investment Banks as the beta
for the restaurant he said but I'm not
an investment bank so I came ready I
actually showed him a table of revenues
at five star restaurants the Restaurant
Association of New York maintains and
revenues at investment
Banks and I showed the correlation I
said look when investment Banks do well
your seats all fill up they do badly
they're all
empty so when you think about risk what
you looking for companies that do well
when you do well do badly when you do
badly and once you've got that that is
your you're not pricing companies you're
not looking at PE ratios you don't have
to worry about all the rest of the stuff
this is about Market risk and you're
trying to find other companies with
similar Market risk so be creative don't
get mean in in Banks you often get
people getting sic codes naics codes
four-digit codes lookup companies that's
incredibly rigid and you're missing the
point you're missing the point about
what you're trying to do here and if you
haven't accessed Capital IQ yet I know
we've been harassing you about it this
is the time to do it maybe right after
the quiz get on Capital IQ because you
can pull up those companies you can pull
up the market cap it's a two-minute job
for any sector you can pull up all of
the information you had there you could
do the long way with the yaho finance
but why right so I will see you on
Monday again remember 10:30 to 11: is
your quiz and then we have class so
don't leave after the quiz anger out
um I'm Camila by the way um I emailed
you a few weeks ago that I'm not gonna